[موسيقى]
القبله هي وجهه المصلي وكانت القبله قبل
هجره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم الى
المدينه بيت المقدس وفي 17 رجب من السنه
الثانيه للهجره تحولت القبله من بيت
المقدس الى مكه والقبله تحدد عن طريق
الشمس بالنهار وعن طريق النجوم بالليل
فالشمس اساسا في تحديد مواقيت الصلاه
والقبله اقم الصلاه لدلوك شمس الى غسق
الليل وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر كان
مشهودا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فيوم السبت والاحد والاثنين ستمر الشمس
فوق الكعبه وقت اذان الظهر على الحرم في
تمام الساعه 12:27 دقيقه فالشمس في هذه
اللحظه هي القبله عالميا فمن يشاهد الشمس
سواء كان عندهم صبح او ظهر او عصر فهو
مستقبل للقبله والشمس تمر فوق الكعبه
مرتين بس سنه مرت وهي طالعه فوق لمدار
السرطان في 27 مايو ومره ثانيه وهي نازله
تحت لمدار الجدي في 16 يوليو قد نرى تقلب
وجهك في السماء فلا نولينك قبله ترضاها
فولي وجهك شطر المسجد الحرام وحيث ما كنتم
فولوا وجوهكم شاطره
[موسيقى]